welcome back to the Rich Eisen show the
host of talk is Jericho the popular
podcast on podcast one the lead singer
of Fozzy as well as the recent signee
with all elite wrestling Chris Jericho
good to see I should say it's Westwood
when I switched really yeah so we better
say Westwood One or I'll get in trouble
talk is Jericho podcast on Westwood
nailed it one there we go mind yes
straight off the card I should have just
appeared sometimes I do i do Ron
Burgundy or do I not do it just go
straight with what I read so that put a
lot of pressure on a sportscaster sense
of their self little point that happened
but you you played band on the run on
your Instagram story we were saying
earlier I figured out how to play music
on the story and when you guys had your
store I was giving the show today I
restored it and added music ah because
whenever I see your logo it reminds me
of Band on the Run fantastic the
fugitive I'm like the fusion of
sportscaster you know I get it whenever
people look at the logo I get I get a
lot of Mad Men you even had Jon Hamm mr.
Draper himself came on the show and said
it looks very Mad Men ish instead of me
falling off a building I'm running
straight out so if you could put a prop
plane behind you
it's North West Cary Grant I will take
the career ant that's now Harris has got
McCartney Jon Hamm and Cary Grant are
the first two minutes of the show three
very handsome mothers just cut it off
right now she just we should just thank
you good night everybody mic drop so not
many people can say that the pride of
Manhasset New York and also Winnipeg yes
but you are both in a way yes you're
born in Manhasset right I was born in
Manhattan because my dad used to play
for the Rangers as we were discussing
for you haven't dude so they used to
have their training camp the Rangers had
their training camp in Manhattan which
is Long Island right but I guess they
wanted to stay out of the city so that's
why I was born but then moved to
Winnipeg as my dad was from Winnipeg
funny story in about the mid-2000s when
Vince McMahon decided that you couldn't
be from Canada and be a baby face in the
WB for whatever reason no because no one
would cheer a Canadian was
mindset are you serious I'm not kidding
so I was told that you can't be from
Winnipeg anymore
you're from Tampa I'm like why I'm only
live in tap I'm not further where were
you born man hasit that sounds too
country enough from Manhattan New York
so for a clue because we've heard many
stories mostly here in Los Angeles
regretful your your name is no longer
that your name is this right that's the
way we're so a Vince McMahon sits you
down and says a very team America thing
to blame Canada so he says you're not
from Canada you're from well there was a
whole bunch of us that were Canadian
Canadian I grew up in Canada Winnipeg
who was Canadian
well edge Christian Val Venis a bunch of
the guys at the time and he just decided
one time that you cannot be a babyface a
good guy and be from Canada for people
to really cheer you you have to be from
the United States probably lasted for
about six months but that's sometimes
Vince would go through these type of
things where you there's no there's no
no DDT's anymore damn it too many DDT's
and then six months later why are there
any DDT's on the damn show so that was
so that was when I was from Manhattan
okay New York well then you just open
your mouth you still sound you know
Canadian super Canadians that's where I
grew up man and this is even like
curtailing the accent cuz when you go
back there you get super Canadian right
rich what's going on man how's it going
got some water in the cop having a great
time here on your show Mon that's like
super yeah it's funny for me that when I
do go back to New York it does slip out
a little bit myself when you're around
the atmosphere it does right at doing
the my job the way you know I used to
when I started out my career I'd say the
word tournament mmm the NC double-a
tournament you know and so I literally
in my first TV job I to write the word
tournament down tu RN - Ament but you
caught me off in traffic The New Yorker
will come in right yeah that's the way
because that's when you grew up with
that that's thus your speech patterns
right I get that
so now since we
spoke here on the show Chris Jericho you
let it be known to me before you came
out here that you have picked up fandom
of the National Football League for the
very first time correct
yeah I have my wife is a huge NFL fan so
she was always into the Vikings in the
FEL and I just couldn't be bothered and
fine fine I'll give this a try okay I'll
give this football thing a try all you
walk in and your Sunday Night Football
and all this other stuff your Super Bowl
and there's actually really got into it
I really enjoyed it it's a lot of fun
yeah secret has been revealed so uh
Vikings fan not happy with Kirk Cousins
and is 84 million dollar contract
couldn't even get it in the playoffs it
sound like you're real you don't have to
be a fan for very long to start laying
into people just hating everything and
that's the thing about fans like
wrestling fans yeah kiss fans Star Wars
fans football fans are all the same they
love their team their band the wrestlers
but they hate everything that they do
and that's kind of what it is when
you're an NFL fan well it's also sounds
like that sounds like a New England
sports fan to where you're not happy
unless you're thoroughly unhappy right
it's like you the people are bagging on
a Tom Brady for winning you know six
Super Bowls yes and as if like he's like
the scourge of the earth like he is now
become a Atilla the Hun mm-hmm because
he's not used to be like that with
Gretzky in the eighties too though
growing up in Winnipeg everybody hated
Gretzky what cuz he was so good and used
to murder that Winnipeg Jets okay I
think if you look at Gretzky's point
totals the team that he scored the most
points against was one of the Jets so we
hated him because he was so great but
that's part of sports like you hate him
but have you ever got traded to the Jets
there'd be a ticker tape parade you'd be
running down the street with 99 tattooed
on your eye was that way about Dan
Marino as a New York jet fan and had the
Jets ever acquired Dan Marino instantly
huge love huge right oh yeah and that's
just that that's sports I think you know
sure I always think of like the thrill
of victory the agony of defeat Wide
World of Sports that is such the
greatest quote ever because there's not
like we went to the game
at the at the Dome in Minnesota the
hapless yeah where it was such a dumb
thing if the Vikings won one of the last
two games they would have been in the
playoffs or if the other teams would
have lost their games yes but no they
Vikings lost theirs who the teams won
theirs so we're at the dome in
Minneapolis when they all they had to do
was either win this game or the Eagles
had to lose theirs correct and week 17
against the Bears you were in that
building yeah okay was the worst this is
it this is this season yeah right and it
was the worst because if Phillies
winning forty five to to Minnesota's
losing forty five to two he just like he
could on the ultimate high right and
just said the enemy like this the Sox
man let's just go like I wish I never
even came like that's how you feel right
yeah you know but it's the experience it
was a blast but a good time but still
well this is why Chris Jericho you can
go from not caring about football one
year to bitching about Kirk Cousins the
next next consistently and you look you
do this goal chant the whole thing you
get that much into it I don't know what
school means to me school is like
chewing tobacco that used to come in a
little it's a difficult call them school
then yeah but these would come a little
uh bite-size packages oh you'd put it in
nervous go bandits yes cool bandits
right but that's with an a yes and yeah
this is with an I think an ohm lot over
the old if you have a lot then it's
heavy metal something I'm into it I've
always been taught never go full room
long never go full of life under man you
can't figure it out hey we play a game
called celebrity true or false here
Chris Jericho let's do this with Chris
Jericho here on the rich or false Chris
Jericho you graduated with honors from
Red River College and Winnipeg Manitoba
true or false
middle truth I graduated one semester
with honors I got on the honor roll one
semester which for me it was amazing cuz
I was always like on the dishonor roll
in high school so I'm gonna give it a
slight truth is there such a thing as a
dishonorable just for me there was I'm
up on my high school hallways
dishonorable Jericho I got a
dishonorable discharge from high school
that's an awkward
I've never heard that one before I just
made it up before becoming a
professional wrestler you were a model
and a bouncer in Canada true story
bouncer yes model I don't think it was a
role model you sure
I think one time someone paid me 50
bucks to do a like a lingerie fashion
show where I was like the male guy
walking the girls out so does that count
sure so I guess technically yes I wasn't
what was that
well you got paid 50 bucks Canadian or
American okay hey it was in Calgary at
the time okay so what's your best
bouncer story from your days in Canada
gosh there's so many of them at one time
there was a huge brawl where the roof of
the of the bar caved in literally the
whole roof just fell I had nothing to do
with the brawl some kind of a water pipe
there's like something out of the movie
where the Jets versus sharks all lined
up for the big fight you know there's
gonna be a rumble tonight okay here we
go
fights over because the ceiling came is
it collapse is everyone alive no one
died okay it ended the fight did you you
didn't bounce the ceiling is muscle I
was happy as I didn't have to get into
the fight I just hang on the backhand
and talk to girls did you did you ever
get in a fight couple times a couple
times okay yeah you took this neon Issei
I tuned him I tuned it to me you took
the stage name of Jericho from the album
walls of Jericho from German power metal
band Halloween true story
yeah I was gonna call myself Jack action
and hold on a second you were that that
was your first yeah you didn't Chris no
no just Jack action okay first name Jack
last name action I was gonna make a
million dollars and then I told somebody
of that and they're like you cabbie Jack
to action that's stupid Oh Mike of
course is stupid I would never do that
what's your name and I was like and I
saw the Halloween album I said Chris
Jericho that's that's no you could be
talking to Jack action then things have
done differently it's just normal Chris
Jericho I just I'm just gonna throw it
out like this you know and I obviously
things happen for a reason right and to
me I think destinies what you make of
yourself yes but all that self all that
said I don't believe you would have had
the success that you had
if you were in fact Jack action I
probably have to agree with Vince
McMahon would have stopped you right
there Jack action oh so crass that's a
good Vince word crass uses that word us
all the time so when he says that the
XFL is not gonna have anybody that's had
any police record at all he really means
it that's not some sort of that's what
he says yeah I mean I don't know who's
left at this point with right I fell
then there's a new is the AAF that's the
only on right now what I mean if that's
what he says then yeah he's pretty uh
strict to his beliefs okay last one for
you on your birthday you've you fly to
Mexico then to Japan then back to Mexico
so you can celebrate two birthdays in
different time zones that's true it'll
seat smoking in the economy - section do
you really fly around so you could
celebrate why not like every year
so you do it once you didn't want I
ain't like 95 or so I was I wanted to
see how long I could stay on the road
for cuz I was living in a dumpy little
apartment in Vancouver with two other
dudes at one bedroom right so I had a
job in Japan and a job in Mexico I just
said I'll see how long I could stay on
the road for so I just flew back and
forth for like six months and during one
of those trips just happened to be in my
birthday 48-hour Burt that's amazing so
congratulations on signing with all
elite wrestling thank you brother what
is what is this brother have you threw
in the brother that brother what do you
what does this mean for you I mean so
what happened was basically the family
that owns the Jacksonville Jaguars the
Khan family you know Tony I do his
father shot yeah
all of these factors kind of took place
at the same time to start this company
whereas you had a group of guys who were
worldwide famous but not super
well-known in the States
other than amongst hardcore fans yes
guys like kenny omega young bucks cody
rhodes those type of guys and then you
had Tony with his backing and then you
had all this interest in television
wrestling and so basically for the first
time possibly ever we have an
alternative to the WB and it was a real
cool concept for me
from a creative side and from a buzz
side and our first shows at the MGM
Grand that we sold it out in four
minutes last week no one so there's a
huge buzz of fans who want to see this
alternative wrestling company well your
I mean your popularity has never been
bigger and that's saying a lot right now
I mean you're over three million
followers at Chris Jericho Fozzie on
Instagram I am Jericho on Twitter your
podcast on Westwood One all elite
wrestling and then your rock band Fozzy
now I'm wondering if we could if you
wouldn't mind lending us the ability to
promote your band for just a sure for
ten days we just need it for 10 days
okay
in July what do we got going on so the
New York Knicks have an opportunity
right now to get a whole bunch of free
agents like Kevin Durant and Kyrie
Irving it's a possibility for them to
get them we need to get their awful
owner out of town mm-hmm
when the free agent window opens that we
need James Dolan out of town so we're
gonna invite him to headline a fire fest
that Mike Dell Tufo our sound engineer
executive audio exactly but all the
executives we need we need to dress it
up can we say that Fozzie is playing in
this fire fest
I think we've actually already been
booked I just heard about it yesterday
in fact so far using your word yep
and like I said in our contract you want
the cheese and bread platter we've got
these luxury accommodations let's just
leave it okay great just leave it at
that not the jury comped mustard there
they are luxury accommodation gotcha
perfect and we get to tell James Dolan
of JD in the straight shot that's the
name of his band okay my fuzzy and I
think Jamie shots a dumb name well how
did Fozzie come back Oh basically we
started as a cover band and we just said
well be will be Fozzie Osbourne and that
that was years ago and then because
there was such a buzz about us we just
dropped the the Osborne and kept Fozzie
which if you look at Metallica and kiss
and Red Hot Chili Peppers and black-eyed
peas Def Leppard very strange names and
then they just become names name yeah
and actually we're opening for Iron
Maiden at the Bank of California stadium
here in Los Angeles in September and
September yes okay so so what better way
to get things moving than appearing in
the Mike del 2 faux fire fest it's
perfect that we're still we're still
we're still putting together right the
video yet we're working on a still
working location yeah no location set
okay
we're not we're gonna use his Instagram
feed not yours
okay perfect I don't put an orange dot
on I mean if you wish if you want that's
entirely up to send you the promo video
don't send me the promo dot we all have
to do this at the same time right to
make sure I don't know if we're letting
the cat out of the bag by talking about
it on live radio on television it's okay
but we do promotion we got it we got
with James Dolan's out of town so fuzzy
is part of this DJ mr. big chest is is
spinning spinning okay thank you for
lending us Fozzie for that purposes and
all New York Knick fans think that's
what you need you have to get the free
agents that's that's what aw we got the
free agents you know there's a
connection understand that's that's
right just imagine if we had to get that
the cons if let's just imagine the cons
were the worst owners in sports rights
they're not what they're not the worst
owners right sports and we have to get
them out of town when free agency
happens he's on the straight shooters
Jayden JD just JD cuz it's James Dolan
gotcha and the straight shot it's a
straight shot no I okay it's a straight
shot from LA to San Diego on the i-5 I
thought I what he's talking about just
like let's just I have no idea what the
straight shot is all we gotta do is we
gotta get him a straight shot out of
town gotcha straight shot from from New
Jersey to Schenectady the mic tell to
foe fire fest is blowing up right now
yes and wait till you post delays on
your Instagram food I mean it's going
over the top kids call it lit lit ah
good to see you Christian rich thanks
man you're welcome here always a
pleasure always pleasure hanging out
with
I'm welcome anytime what if you show up
tomorrow I'm sitting in the same chair
told ya yeah let's do it
you guys got popcorn in the dressing
room there Hey look let's stay in myself
we should treat it like it's your
birthday 48 straight hours
it's celebrate two shows and show at I
am Jericho on Twitter and be part of the
3.1 million followers at Chris Jericho
Fozzie on Instagram we'll set up the
rest of the week when we come back the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience